Yes President,
please,
before making USE of my time
I would like 1 point of order.
I don't know why
here it has just been claimed
that the team can take,
that any symbol can be carried
religious and cultural,
and I've just been prevented from going out with the bowl,
which is 1 Palestinian cultural symbol.
I am not advertising,
I don't understand 1 flag of nothing.
But uh,
from here
of this parliament
I have been prevented from going out with the bowl
and it seems to me that there is none.
There is no reason,
there is no standard.
I think it is 1 hitch.
Don't let me come with the cusilla,
eh.
First of all,
it seems to me that Mrs.
Wonder Legend
should have had the decency
of having stayed here
"until the end of this debate.
"
because I have him,
we want to say things to Cara.
No wonder he doesn't stay
because he doesn't have that decency.
I want to start by recognizing
the statement made by Mr.
Borrell in aman
in which he claimed something so revolutionary
as international law.
I believe that today is revolutionary
to vindicate something that had to be Norma
anywhere.
But it turns out that Mrs.
Wonder Legend
and his companion,
Mrs. Mesola.
They have been
in Tel Aviv with unconditional support
to 1 genocidal regime,
to 1 regime that has converted the Gaza Strip
in something very similar to the Warsaw ghetto,
subjecting it to 1
in which they were leaving people to die
no water,
no light,
no fuel,
without medicine,
without food.
But it turns out,
is that it turns out since yesterday,
where it was bombed,
Israel bombed.
What is it that in the previous intervention
has forgotten to say
that these people
died under Israeli bombing.
It has been turned into ation camp.
It is indecent that Mrs.
Wonder read or Mrs.
continue to preside over European institutions.
Please Camp,
please,
I sing well.
They are filling functions with shame.
Thank you very much President